yes it's it's Friday and you know what
that means huh I really have to go to
the bathroom
I'm gonna wait till it's over
let's welcome tonight's guests
this early bird sure is special Fox and
Friends first co-host Carly Simca
believe it or not he's the only guy in
the show tonight named hotep YouTube
host hotep Jesus
he looks like the guy who came to cut
down your trees comedian Jim Florentine
finally she's the first author to weigh
less than her book Fox News contributor
cartoon
[Applause]
tonight okay before we get to some news
stories it's Friday so let's do this
Briggs leftovers
that's leftovers where I read the jokes
we didn't use this week and as always
it's my first time reading these so if
they suck we'll just chemically castrate
Joe Mackey
no not that it would make a difference
but anyway
a man should decide designed to look
like the White House just went up for
sale in California it's such an accurate
replica Hunter Biden keeps trying to
sneak cocaine into it
the FDA claims there have been dozens of
reports that one of ozempik's biggest
side effects is suicide the claim is
being backed heavily by pharmacies as
first-time users never come back for a
refill
suicide is not funny we'll be right back
following his divorce Kevin Costner
reportedly wants to get revenge on his
wife by making her life a living hell
and to do that he plans on making her
watch all five seasons of Yellowstone
it's not that good
a transgender woman recently won the
Miss Netherlands pageant
she credits the judges for not examining
her nether regions
meanwhile other contestants were
surprised at the results but did say the
competition was a little stiff
according to a recent article single
women who booze it up out Sunday brunch
are less likely to meet single men
although they are 100 more likely to
meet gay men
[Applause]
[Laughter]
a new study finds that over half of
America's beaches have dangerous fecal
contamination
to lessen the risk of E coli people are
advised to avoid swimming with Amber
Heard
last Friday the Dutch the Dutch
government collapsed this after they
couldn't agree on splitting a check for
lunch
I know it's stupid but
should I explain it for people who are
under 40 what Dutch used to mean you
know what it means cat
a New Jersey couple stole 91 thousand
dollars from a youth soccer club to pay
for a trip to Disney World yeah like 91
Grand would cover it
after an allergic reaction to smoking
while on antibiotics you know yeah an
Ohio Man's Tongue turned green and hairy
yeah doctors say they haven't seen a
tongue this green since Miss Piggy and
Kermit went to Third Base
[Applause]
what do you think our hand is right now
I believe the TSA is spending more than
a billion dollars on Advanced 3D
scanners that can detect harmful objects
which was great news for me it's how
they found my lost Stretch Armstrong
no
maybe I don't have to go to the bathroom
after all this old Stretch Armstrong all
right let's do some news the White House
gets dragged for not finding out who
left that bag criticisms get louder
about the mysterious Peruvian marching
powder
yeah it's Case Closed into the White
House cocaine mystery after the Secret
Service says they found no evidence
pointing to a suspect Hunter was so
excited about the news he did 14 lines
of Coke
yeah but yeah get this no surveillance
footage no DNA no fingerprints no
nothing and not even a laptop computer
documenting the crime with text emails
and video but if they found that
they just call that Russian
disinformation
so apparently security is so lacks In
The West Wing they even let in Kamala
Harris
[Applause]
but it's good to know if you're planning
anything they may as well put up a
billboard saying with us in charge it's
really easy to assassinate people
naturally ex-federal agents are
skeptical and that's probably why
they're ex-federal agents
one telling the post quote this is a
cover-up it is a restricted area and
they have a log book you don't have to
be Colombo to figure out who was there
it's true but if you were Colombo that
would be weird because you're a TV
character
then you would
be weird being that actually and another
one said they identified hundreds of
people who were in the Capitol building
on January 6 but they don't know who
left something in an 8x10 Room in the
White House
yeah to be fair though some of the
people there at Jan six we're easy to
spot
one veteran investigator asked what
would have happened if it had been a bag
of Anthrax that was an easy answer
Hunter would have snorted that too
[Applause]
all right
Jim uh your let me just try to give you
a synopsis of your life you know you're
a veteran comic you're white you're a
habitual drug user uh known to do
terrible things in hotel rooms if this
was your Coke you'd already be at Rikers
wouldn't you
anyone that does coke is not going to
leave a bag behind like that's that's
smart yes it's like being in the
military never leave a bat behind yeah
yeah something like that yes
so you know look I mean what all the
news with Hunter you know all the stuff
in the news about him it doesn't look
good yeah for him that's like you know
going to O.J Simpson's house now and
finding a bloody knife yeah there's
gonna be some suspicions
um
you know the white house looks stupid
because they're saying we don't know
they put it just put out a statement say
listen we tested the the
um the stuff and it's Joe's Metamucil
yeah
people would believe that like okay he's
an old guy he takes it they should have
a backup story like OJ if you walked in
and you saw a bloody knife I would just
go if I wrote you I'd go into the fridge
and I'd pull out this amazing
Strawberry Shortcake and I go would
you like a slice
and then they go oh my God I'm so sorry
I thought it was blood you're no problem
they just stab him
it's easier to find out just get
everyone that was there that day yeah
put them in a room and just yell all
right who wants to party yeah and
somebody's gonna go me jump someone's
gonna play
[Applause]
Carly you know you've probably covered
this in the morning before any of us are
up
um
I know but doesn't it but it doesn't
when you're doing the story you in your
head there's a script going this is
meaningless okay so you knew that
something was up last week when the
Secret Service came out and said that
they were going to wrap up the
investigation whether they found the
person or not like when does a law
enforcement agency just say that they're
going to throw in the towel and stop
caring that just so that was weird and
then the other thing that was weird
about this is that the cocaine was found
it kept on jumping around as to where it
was found so first it was the library
and then it was The West Wing and then
it ended up being near The Situation
Room where there are no cameras right
interesting uh and then there's the
reaction to the whole thing and Korean
Jean-Pierre saying how dare you even
think that it's the first son's cocaine
it's like he's the one that wrote a book
about being a crack cocaine addict and
we're not even allowed to think it
he did
that's so true you know you say like it
hop from room to room what if it was
Mexican jumping Coke
for growing up with Mexican jumping
beans what
snort one of those
Papa hotep I could finally say I know
what it's like to be black
here you got a white man who you know
gets away with a crime that I would be
arrested for this is what you have dealt
with your entire life my entire life yes
I mean like you run down the list of
jobs where careers I possibly could have
had and I'm probably the guy that would
have sold the coke
right I was a rapper in a form of life
but one career path I never expected was
being a secret service investigator
[Applause]
but you know what we'll perhaps we'll
never know who it is right like we won't
know we don't know if who killed Epstein
we don't know who killed JFK well a
secret I know who did it I know whose
Coke it is yeah I know whose blow it is
yeah I'm just trying to figure out how
they don't know yeah yeah
this is your job yeah
we all know who's it is
okay
just proof that cat we you and I made a
mistake you being a Libertarian and me
being a republican for so long is that
you should have just been Democrats we
could get away with anything
I well I don't know I've made a lot of
mistakes yeah that's true that's true
but I think that if there's a bag of
cocaine you always have lots and lots of
people who do know whose it is because
cocaine is not really a drug that makes
you not talk yeah
this person does so much blow that
they're bringing it to work yeah this
person does a lot of blow they're not
like oh they're not they're not not
telling hundreds of people yeah they
don't know how to shut up because you're
doing cocaine in fact that's a great
strategy for the Secret Service uh to
get everybody in and then just give them
Coke
and then and then uh and then you
interrogate them
what do you think give them Coke to get
to the bottom yeah it is a truth serum
it's an exaggeration of a truth serum
not that I would know I condemn all
drugs
you're not going to answer me you're
just gonna stand should the cops Coke
give people Coke and yeah a serious
question
um I guess if they ask for it I don't
see any problem is that great you don't
force them to have Coke but like would
you like some coke the way they let
people have a cig yes it's exactly like
Law and Order where they get them they
always go get them a burger and a coke
like this let's go like sometimes I'll
be watching that and I'll go you know
what it's not that bad getting arrested
because people go get your food
get me food
[Applause]
see what I mean now I know what it's
like
all right up next will AI beat
Hollywood's Elite hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else